[Musique]
s'approcher vu l'intensité du combat
mieux vaut pas trop quand même il s'est
plutôt violent et plutôt réel être au
plus près du réel c'est le but de cette
première fête médiévale fantastique
breizh artisans ou simples bénévoles ils
mettent tous du coeur à l'ouvragé pour
faire vivre leur passion du moyen âge
bon niveau des tenues on fabrique pas
mal de choses tout ce qui est en bois on
essaie de le faire
l'acier on commande alors dommage que je
vais vous dire mais on commande à
l'étranger parce que les meilleurs à
cesson à l'étranger en république
tchèque en hongrie
voilà généralement de l'est pour la ci
après les boucliers sont made in france
ont ainsi offert au sérieux on lançait
aussi c'est dans le parc du château de
brétignolles que se tient l'événement un
château peu connu qui veut se distinguer
dans le paysage déjà bien fournie de la
région tous les châteaux ont débuté un
jour
donc notre objectif c'est d'ouvrir
chaque année de plus en plus le château
autant à l'intérieur du château que par
exemple le parc on a prévu de réaménager
le potager du château donc pour pouvoir
au public de découvrir les châteaux qui
ont créé spécialement un passage au
château
assurément marquant pour certaines
remises de retourner dans le temps là
pas du tout pas du tout j'aimerais bien
revenir juste avant le coup vide
il ya deux ans
[Rires]